welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 and it's really hard to know where to
start crying first and Rocket's
backstory are the countless possible
deaths that are gonna happen in this
movie let's break down this trailer
frame by frame for everything that you
might have missed and hey if you happen
to be in the LA area this weekend new
rockstars will be at La Comic Con on
Sunday December 4th at 10 30 a.m doing a
panel we really hope to see you there we
would love to chat in person about who's
gonna die in this movie and thanks to
boxu for sponsoring this video more on
their tasty offerings later let's get
started
we were gone for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
okay the Marvel Studios title card cross
dissolves
and it left him but remember the second
of which was destroyed along with
Peter's Walkman by ego and Guardians
volume 2. the tape deck of the ship is
still okay though at least we think it
is their [ __ ] by the way is now the
Bowie which we learned up in the
Guardians holiday special the Bowie is a
three-story ship that replaces the
Benetar which was their ship in Infinity
war end game and Thor 11 Thunder and
that replaced their original first ship
of the Milano Bowie is an appropriate
name for the ship David Bowie's moonage
Daydream did play in that awesome mix
vol 1 as the Guardians first arrived
into nowhere in the 2014 film and
nowhere by the way is now their home
base after they bought it from The
Collector but over the tape deck here
the needle flips back and forth and
particles float in front of the logo
maybe dust or snow not really sure but
it makes me really worried that the
ship's inside could have been exposed to
the zero gravity of space would that
sound needle still work if there's no
sound in space I mean can we test this
please but don't send a dog to do it all
right Pete Leica Peter man's the bridge
of the Bowie no one else in the seats
and he and the other Guardians wear new
uniforms in this movie inspired by the
blue and red uniforms from the Abnet
landing area of the comics it's somewhat
reminiscent of the novocore uniform the
Nova core would likely still be in
shambles after Thanos wrecked xandar to
get a power Stone so the Guardians
really have taken on the role of
Galactic First Responders some might say
guardians of it the Bowie soars into
this planet that at first looks like New
York of Earth but it totally is not
there's something that looks like the
Statue of Liberty front and center there
but Liberty Island doesn't really face
in that direction the terrain is all
different the cityscape behind it is 100
not Manhattan New York and New Jersey
also don't have Hills like that in the
visible distance there is an island on
the left with some shipping cranes and a
cruise liner there's a few triangular
structures along the water that remind
me a lot of the Sydney Opera house when
you look at it from that angle I think
what we are looking at here is a replica
Earth a combination of two Marvel
settings one the high evolutionaries
counter Earth from the comics this is a
purer version of the original Earth that
Herbert Windham places a micro second
out of dimensional sync to hide it from
Earth I know I know awesome but I think
we're also looking at a version of half
world that is Rocket's origin Planet
listed on its xandar booking screen in
the 2014 film so I think the high of
evolutionary created this place as a
home for his Creations the new Men new
men in the comics are humanoid
animalistic bipedal hybrids so really
when we get closer to that Statue of
Liberty I suspect it's going to be a
Planet of the Apes scenario not the 60s
Charlton Heston Statue of Liberty but
really the 2000 Tim Burton Lincoln
Memorial and that statute's gonna have
an animalistic base who knows maybe
Herbert Windham bashes himself a Kang
and makes a huge statue of himself but
yes the high evolutionary who is he he
is Herbert Windham he's going to be
played in this movie by actor chuckuri
Uchi in the comics The evolutionary is
an associate of Mr Sinister Nathaniel
Essex and X-Men villain but Windham is
Marvel's Ultimate geneticist he's known
for experimenting on various life forms
and he breeds these Animal Human hybrids
that he calls the new men and I think
this is what rocket and his old
girlfriend Lila will be revealed to be
in the MCU the Bowie ships colors match
the colors of the guardian's uniforms
and in lehens right in the middle of the
suburb barely missing crushing a few
houses though definitely ruining a few
Lawns there notice though that all the
cars and clothes are from the 1980s the
80s aesthetic will be a big thing in
this movie Peter Quill was abducted in
the year 1988 so all of his interests
are stuck in the 80s also James Gunn has
said that his awesome mix vol 3 has
already been decided and it's mostly
going to be 80s songs he's known for
writing tracklist actually into a script
because usually all of his songs have a
diegetic role in The Narrative so why
the 80s well I wonder if Wyndham's move
to create the new men in counter Earth
half world could have come out of a
survivalist Panic that many felt in the
1980s during that cold war brickmanship
when everyone was super anxious that the
world was gonna nuke itself so maybe in
that Panic a super brilliant but always
overthinking things Herbie was like fine
damn yourselves out of hell i'll build
another Earth and I'll populate it with
my animal people and the 80s will live
on forever on to the next section hello
we come in peace
okay
come on tracks seriously dude
okay as the Guardians deboard the Boeing
notice it's just Peter mantis nebula
Drax and swole Groot no Gamora yet and
no rocket I think they have come here
looking for Rocket who maybe went
looking for his home world and his old
friends the locals are all suspicious
one is carrying a fly spotter really the
longer you look at these guys the
freakier they get like the postal worker
looks like a bird maybe a peacock but
has five humanoid fingers that are Talon
claws ugh I also just like the idea in
this world mail still might be delivered
by birds even birds that don't fly
because they don't have wings but they
still just walk and drive around the guy
who shouts at him is a rabbit whose ears
are now drooped down like long hair of a
professor and behind him there's another
bird beaked man but with hair like the
Muppet Bert there's also a panda and a
polo shirt tucked into jeans jeans held
up by a belt I hope that belt isn't made
of leather now that street sign has some
alien language on it it's kind kind of
hard to make out but it's another
indicator that this isn't like a an
Ultimate Reality Earth is another planet
that was created to be an alien world
like notice how they all speak in
another language
Drax pegs this poor kid with a kickball
that sound is really seared in my memory
from all my Years playing Jim dodgeball
really I'm less worried about the ball
hitting her face than I am by that
girl's head hit in the pavement no no no
the Guardians all get pelted and drax's
reaction is surprising considering
bullets tickled him in the guardian's
holiday special also notice how small
group doesn't duck recover at all even
when a rock hits him right in the head
moving on
[Music]
don't forget
where are we in him from okay the music
in Australia is space hogs in the
meantime from 1995. it's a glam rock hit
from their album resident alien they
were heavily influenced by David Bowie
actually that
[Music]
loop at the beginning was influenced by
the dial tone one would hear when you
make a call from the U.S to the UK and
you get a cross line the lead singer
said it's the sound of a phone ringing
and being engaged at the same time the
lead singer Royston Langdon said that
this song in general is him trying to
reach people find an end to isolation it
reminds us a lot of rocket in this movie
someone who is desperate to reconnect to
his roots but the timing just not really
connecting we see that Peter has his
headphones in remember since ego
destroyed his Walkman I assume this is
the Zune that yondu left him at the end
of volume 2 and all the music we hear in
this movie is going to be messages from
yondu mantis says don't forget about
where we came from and we learned in the
holiday special that mantis is Peter's
half-sister both of them children of ego
who is a Celestial this ancestry will
likely play a big role in the story what
does it mean for them to have Celestial
DNA especially now that we know more
about celestials after the eternals film
why did that DNA pass on to Peter and
Peter was able to activate it while so
many other of ego's Offspring died also
a reminder to everyone that James Gunn's
long-lost hidden Easter egg from the
Guardians movies is still undiscovered
but likely has something to do with
Meredith quill and all those location
coordinates that we see throughout the
films James Gunn has said over the years
that new rock stars and Mt who was
really the pioneer of trying to decode
this stuff and various others online
have gotten close to uncovering it fully
but not all the way yet ultimately I
think it's gonna be all about Meredith
will and what about her DNA made Peter
Quill so uniquely successful to carry
this Celestial DNA from higo and I think
mantis as the external hard drive of all
of ego's guilt might know more about
that secret from Meredith because ego
was the one who gave Meredith quill that
brain tumor so we see baby rocket in a
cage as a hand reaches out to grab him
you look closely rocket is not alone in
that cage could these other fuzzballs
include Lila could rocket have siblings
that he doesn't know about I assume this
is the hand of Herbert Windham before
Herbert cybernetically experiments on
Rocket to give him intelligence this
matches the footage from the Comic-Con
trailer that showed a close-up of a pen
writing 89p 13 which was the number on
Rocket's booking screen on xandar in the
first film we see five guardians
floating out into space wearing
multi-colored spacesuits looking like
those from the Among Us game now in
reality these are actually a nod to the
red yellow and blue spacesuits in 2001 A
Space Odyssey one of two references to
Kubrick's classic in this trailer you
could also say we got 5 out of six
infinity stone colors here minus a
purple one for the Power Stone later we
see that it's Peter in the yellow suit
mine Stone mantis and the orange suit
Soul Stone Drax in the red suit reality
Stone and then nebula and Gomorrah are
in the green and blue suits so you know
time and space I don't know if there's
any connection there but groups is not
with them here in the later shot we can
see that mantis's arm has a strip with
six rainbow colors on it really what is
this massive fleshy structure that
they're leaping down onto we get a
better look at it later throughout the
trailer you can see this flesh has hairs
poking out of it as they jump across it
I speculate this could be spinal or
nerve tissue from the rest of nowhere's
body that ringed hole with the
construction line and it could actually
be nowhere's eye sock an optical nerve
upon getting torn out before or maybe
even after he was beheaded the Guardians
travel all over the Galaxy and that
takes fuel I also run on fuel but that
fuel is snacks but not just any snacks
I'm spoiled now in the boxu boxu is my
favorite Japanese snack subscription box
they work with family businesses all
across Japan to deliver a new theme of
authentic treats every month your first
box that you get will be Seasons of
Japan and then after that you get a new
monthly theme like this one this month's
theme is Hokkaido Wonderland which
showcases traditional winter flavors
from Japan's northernmost Island let's
see what do I want to try what do I want
to try I'm gonna try the Morimoto cookie
ask up
hmm oh so the hacks app is the blue
honey berry which can only be found in
Hokkaido it's buttery it's tart it's so
good
so the nice thing about box suit is that
when you really fall in love with a
snack like I just did with this one you
can stock up on your favorites through
baksu Boutique both eye and the new
Rockstar's office have been receiving
these boxes for ages we love them so
much and boxing makes a really great
gift for the travel lover in your life
or just really for any person who
appreciates good food if you give baksu
as a present you get to give someone you
love a fun and unique food experience
and support our Channel at the same time
it's really a win-win so click the link
in the description and use the code
rockstars to get 15 off your order let's
move on
whole lives
I'm done running
Gamora looks at a Polaroid not sure what
of yet maybe something Peter gave her to
try to remind her of his years with the
original 616 Gamora we know about the
Comic-Con footage that Gamora will be
leading a side group of ravagers the
Guardians March through the streets of
nowhere that's the same set that we saw
in the Guardians holiday special from
the right that's mantis Drax rocket is
sipping something and then nebula is
carrying Peter then we see Groot and
craglin and Cosmo the space dog now
Cosmo was reintroduced in the holiday
special first scene as one of the
collector's items in the 2014 film Cosmo
is based on Leica the poor Russian space
dog thus the Soviet letters on their
spacesuit and the comics Cosmo has
telepathic and telekinetic Powers we saw
a little bit of that in the holiday
special but the dog now has a voice
caller that's voiced by actress Maria
bakalova that was the actress in Borat
too gun has suggested that Cosmo is
closest to craglin of the Guardians and
Cracklin did say in the holiday special
that he learned about what Christmas was
from Cosmo who learned it from rocket so
why is Peter incapacitated here maybe
drank himself into a stupor after being
rejected by Gamora nebula is the one
carrying him not Drax not Groot so
nebula's got some impressive strength
James Gunn has suggested that nebula is
now more of an authority figure of
nowhere remember that she and Rocket are
older than the rest of them because
nebula and Rockets survived the blip and
lived all during those five years rocket
loads up his gun in this fire-stricken
location the right of him that is
gamora's hand so she has joined up with
them at this point there's also this
other four-legged creature on the ground
in the background on the right we see
that same thing trotting behind all of
them in this later shot in this trailer
reminds me a lot of Morris from chongqi
but remember Morris had six legs so I
don't know this could just be another
one of windham's lab experiments we all
fall in love with and buy plush toys up
we see Herbert Windham High evolutionary
as this woman jogs and a ring around him
reminding us of that jogging scene in
2001 at Space Odyssey Windham Citadel is
dark Sleek menacing reminding us of he
who remains Citadel and Loki but without
all those kinsugi crack patterns Gamora
and mantis help Drax who's been shot in
the chest as Peter holds nebula behind
them I assume this is the bright white
interior of the glowing white inside of
that fleshy structure that we saw
earlier notice how similar Pink Matter
is covering the surfaces inside of here
Peter holds some spherical object I
don't really know what it is or what the
hell is going on in all these shots but
there are people in other similar suits
floating around them but their suits
have a lot more nodes on their limbs
than on their backs and the Guardians
suits did then the shot of the Bowie
crashing through this barrier now
compared to the shots that we've seen of
ships jumping through the hexagonal U
and T end and the MCU this looks far
more chaotic like either the untn didn't
open properly for them or they met some
barrier that they had to force their way
through if we aren't looking at counter
Earth this could be them forcing their
way through some dimensional riff okay
rocket is in rough shape he's lying on
this grate that's covered in debris
there are new scars on his face
revealing the cybernetic layers beneath
and he says we'll all fly away together
one last time into the forever and
beautiful sky oh my God many are
speculating that rocket will die in this
movie and I guess that's possible I just
think that would be too obvious of a
conclusion to draw from this trailer
like if they want that to be a surprise
they're doing a really bad job hiding it
but I don't know if we're looking at his
death scene here like notice that rocket
doesn't not seem to be wearing anything
here and other than when he was brought
into the kill in prison rocket is almost
always wearing clothes so I think what
we could be looking at here is a
flashback to Rocket's earlier days when
he was windham's lab experiment he's
either lying on the base of his cage
here or he's in the process of an escape
attempt either way talking to someone
like Lila across the bars trying to
instill hope and her and all the other
hybrids that they might be able to
escape together someday I think rocket
up until this point thought he might
have been the last of his kind but in
this movie he's gonna realize that
that's not the case then Peter tackles
someone out of a window this structure
is high above the ground with a red Lego
brick looking to the side first thing he
tackles where's white boots and a white
trench coat and other people dress this
way lie nearby on the ground they're all
bald with cybernetic implant heads like
what nebula has but with yellowish skin
the sky and brown below actually match
the terrain of that maybe counter Earth
maybe half World location that we talked
about before I think this is a high
evolutionaries castle or his floating
base and these white dress people are
The Enclave The Enclave in the comics is
the cult of scientists who create Adam
Warlock and I think in this movie The
Enclave will be the ones who supplied
Aisha with Adam Warlock cocoon in the
comments Adam Warlock leaves The Enclave
he flies into space and he runs into the
high evolutionary who gives him the name
warlock then after that he meets The
Universal Church of Truth who worship
him but I think this group here is the
enclave and in this movie they're going
to be windham's group of genetic
scientists in volume 2 yandu referred to
the scientists that made rocket I think
these are the scientists also I think
there's a parallel here with windham's
look Windham is also bald and has
cybernetic plugs in the back of his head
I think this movie's just going to
simplify everything to have Adam Warlock
be a creation of her Wyndham who leads
to enclave and by the way though we do
not see them in this trailer both
Elizabeth Debicki and Sylvester Stallone
are credited among the cast at the end
of the trailer so we can't expect to see
both Aisha and stacar ogord remember is
the leader of the ravagers will and
Groot flee the crashing Bowie ship
nebula cheers in a celebration among the
other refugees of nowhere then Herbert
Wyndham looks barely disappointed in
that same Hangar Bay that we saw the
Guardians in before the one that was on
fire debris flies around him looking a
lot like the dust that appeared over the
Marvel Studios logo in the opening shot
then a close-up of a drop of blood and
then Peter Wales and Agony over what I
assume is an operating table with a
breathing tube someone dying in front of
him so who dies in this movie if the
blood drop is from this scene it's
probably not Groot here because you know
Groot doesn't really bleed like we do
also we already got a group Death in the
first movie so yeah we could be looking
at Rocket I just don't think that
earlier shot is from its death scene
specifically but it could be someone
else like notice this shot rocket is
hugging this trash otter this is Lila
Rocket's companion who is listed on his
xandar booking screen in the 2014 film
in the comics Lila is Rocket's soulmate
from half world and the heiress to a toy
company but notice here she has
cybernetic pause really a clamp on each
hand but in the shot where he hugs her
rocket again is not wearing clothes his
head is a bit smaller behind them in
this location are a bunch of other cages
so yeah this is a flashback probably the
moment they escaped and when they parted
ways so will Lila reunite with rocket in
the present did she make it also who do
we think will voice Lila Maybe Daniella
melchior who has been confirmed to play
some small unknown role in this movie
and did work with James Gunn on The
Suicide Squad she played rat catcher 2.
others have wondered Lady Gaga said she
did play Bradley Cooper's lover and A
Star is Born I don't know about that but
really that one shot of the blood
dropping what is it dropping bro is that
a hook is that the edge of Lila's hand
clamp just think about it the saddest
option for who could die in the scene
with quill screaming could just be Lila
and all of them are sad because they
know how important Lila is to Rock It
mantis nebula and Drax run into
Annapolis remember these were the
interdimensional squid monsters that
they fought for the Sovereign at the
beginning of volume 2 and then we get
our first look at Will Poulter as Adam
Warlock his bolt and his forehead a nod
to Adam Warlock in the comics having one
of the Infinity Stones The Soul Stone in
his forehead a trait that the MCU
instead gave to Vision with a mind Stone
Holter has described Adam Warlock as a
character with a newborn infantile mind
while Vision minted ironically Adam
really was born yesterday and he shows
it he gives nebula the scut Farkas
treatment nebula appears to be wearing
some kind of chainmail armor that covers
her arm you can see that catwalk Bridge
of nowhere in the background seems like
Adam has tracked the Guardians down to
nowhere mantis sobs in a location with
the same lighting as a place where Peter
cries remember she is an emotional
empath her sorrow is likely to be
heightened in this moment as she's going
to be feeling the grief of all the
survivors here along with her own greed
rocket is seen in a white glowing realm
that looks like an ethereal version of
that cage-filled lab you can see the
outline of the cages behind him he's
once again not wearing clothes and his
cybernetic bolts are visible on his
chest so maybe rocket is flatlined or
he's close to death and his mind is
transporting him back to the place where
he met Lila and speaking of characters
dying swole Groot says we are Groot
which is Father ogroot only said as his
final words when he gave up his life all
of the times Groot just makes the sound
I am Groot with subtle vocal and tonal
variances on that which is where the
different words come in Peter and Groot
are in a shootout with those Enclave
folks and their soldiers I think this
shot is coming right before Peter
tackles one of them out the window now
watching the Guardians holiday special a
lot of folks were freaked out by small
group's form but now you can see it
serves a practical purpose it's just a
bunch of extra limbs and branches tucked
in there ready to clutch multiple things
at once and I love what we can to Black
right as Groot shoots the camera the
title revealed translates from Cree
letters to English as it illuminates in
the Comic-Con trailer we actually saw
nebula putting up this side so this
might be an actual sign in the movie
that gets set up on nowhere onto the
final clip kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad yes the one stupid guy who
no one loves
no one loves him suggests that Herbie
had to create his new men because no one
else would love him like Michael Scott
wanted 100 kids so we can have 100
friends and no one can say no to be in
his friend like mantis lecturing Drax
against killing cops in the holiday
special Drax restraining themselves from
using deadly force will be a recurring
challenge to him in this movie I cannot
wait to explore this movie on a deeper
thematic level because as many of you
know that the first Guardians of the
Galaxy film is my favorite MCU film and
very soon you are about to hear about a
huge new thing that new rockstars is
gonna launch that makes me very excited
that this film is coming in the next
year I can't say too much about it yet
but you will know soon and I have very
big plans for Guardians volume 3 in
particular you can follow me on Tick
Tock Hive Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you